[Music]
let me thank all of you for holding on
so long all day this is really amazing
the room was full at 9:00 a.m. and it's
still pretty full now it's amazing in
this horrible weather I I really loved
the day because I think it did I I know
this this was the panel that was called
the future but I think in a sense all of
it was about the future I think that
looking talking about theory as Robert
digraphs panel did about the beauty
about these ideas that we find and we
follow and that resonate and give us new
ways of looking at the world and have a
you know pay off and on anticipated ways
as you know that the gems that are
thinking will always do and then the
second panel on machine learning which
you know now there's so much hype around
machine learning but there is also so
much promise and so many questions I
think for us you know the yes there's
there are so many applications of
machine learning that we have yet to see
you know in the healthcare domain and in
so many other domains but but I think
again we're going to find that strand of
beauty we don't yet understand why it
works and I think that will bring those
of us who love theory and those of us
who care deeply about the social good
that can come out of machine learning
together we are really just at the very
beginning of machine learning then I
guess we had the the panel on platforms
which I found amazing from you know
scholars who really study platforms with
their
books which were amazing too
you know someone who's the chief
economist for one of the biggest
platforms in the world and one that is
most functional due to the fact that it
came with its own set of social norms
you know which was really a blessing for
LinkedIn right
the other ones what were the norms who
knows
and with Bridget on it who how many
millions of followers does she have 4.6
million followers I mean just amazing so
just and I love the fact that she's back
in grad school as she creates this
following she's studying this following
and that was to mean there was just
amazing and then the Fate panel Hannah's
fate panel fairness accountability
transparency and ethics which i think is
one of the most important developments
in you know of the past decade that we
want to find ways to rather than having
AI compound the in justices make things
less interpretable rather than doing
that having a a I help us ultimately to
make decisions that are fairer than
human judgments but we must define what
we mean by fairness which is why we must
work with legal legal scholars and
ethicists and philosophers and then
finally this panel which as you can see
I stacked with people who don't make
wild predictions of the future but who
ground us and and provide motivations
for that path we should be looking
towards you know taking all these other
things into it I mean I just I love this
lab
oh I love MSR in general and and really
you know I am deeply indebted to
Microsoft for supporting us in doing
this kind of research I think we're
pretty smart so we figure out ways to
make this pay off for the company
because we live in a world of incentives
but you know it's it's just an
additional constraint we want to do
great things create great social good
and also you know make this a good
proposition so that other companies will
do those you know as I say the just
another constraint and the unconstrained
life is not worth living so thank you
everyone we comb in more Lika and her
committee put together this amazing
program one thing this happened to me as
I get one more Labs to manage more more
jobs that and amazing and I let go the
planning of this - Nicole who did an
amazing job and - Lauren who's back
there who doesn't like to be called out
but there she is
I only trust brilliant perfectionist and
both of you are thanks so much Jennifer
it was a great pleasure to share this
wonderful day with all of you and I'm
quite pleased I mean we could give a
round of applause to all of our
panelists that we chose very well there
is now a reception from 5:00 to 7:00
with a live band there's going to be a
little surprise around 5:30 I think so
stick around it'll be great